[Aplausos]
[Música]
durante las últimas décadas chile ha
sido algo así como el cristiano ronaldo
de américa latina' el país que más
crecía que más éxitos tenía en
definitiva el que más goles marcaba
también para muchos liberales chile ha
sido durante años la referencia a seguir
creo que podemos decir que veían al
modelo chileno como una especie de sueño
en un mundo de oscuras tinieblas y lo
cierto amigos es que hay unos motivos
para tantos fuegos artificiales chile
que fue el territorio español más pobre
de latinoamérica se ha convertido hoy en
el país más rico en el país con más
esperanza de vida y en el país con el
mayor índice de desarrollo social de
toda la región es verdad en chile aún
hay mucha desigualdad pero toda esta
prosperidad ha beneficiado a todos los
colectivos del país por ejemplo en los
últimos 25 años el ingreso de los más
pobres ha crecido bastante más que el de
los más ricos
y su capacidad de compra se ha
multiplicado por 6 pero que supone todo
esto si lo comparamos con otros países
latinoamericanos pues fijaos en 1950 el
ingreso del chileno promedio era
prácticamente un tercio del ingreso que
tenía un venezolano es decir los
venezolanos eran tres veces más ricos
desde entonces las cosas como creo que
ya os imagináis amigos de visual
política han cambiado bastante y hoy los
chilenos son mucho más ricos que los
venezolanos y ojo también tienen una
esperanza de vida bastante mayor de
media un chileno vive ocho años más que
una persona nacida en venezuela
vamos que las cosas parece que se han
hecho relativamente bien ahora la
pregunta es cómo ha conseguido chile
este cambio pues básicamente apostando
por buenas políticas como impuestos
comedidos abriéndose al mundo chile soy
el país con más acuerdos comerciales o
apostando por la libertad de empresa
todo esto lo vimos con más detalle en un
pasado vídeo aquí en visual político os
dejo el enlace en la descripción en este
vídeo fonseca nos alertaba de una cosa
compararse con la venezuela o la
argentina en las últimas décadas es
relativamente fácil pero cuando
comparamos a chile con otros países por
ejemplo de asia los números ya no son
tan bonitos y lo que es peor la máquina
parece estar parándose
e
[Música]
el frenazo chileno
en los últimos años ese tiempo de vino
champagne y rosas durante el cual chile
parecía comerse el mundo se ha terminado
en santiago de chile la gran capital del
país las muestras de prosperidad han
dejado paso a manifestaciones y
protestas el enfado y el desánimo es
general y no es para menos en los
últimos años el crecimiento económico se
ha desplomado en 2016 comenzó a
destruirse empleo los salarios no crecen
entre los jóvenes el desempleo está por
las nubes y tanto la inversión como las
exportaciones han caído abruptamente en
los últimos años
[Aplausos]
y lo peor de todo es que las
expectativas no son buenas en 2016 la
economía chilena creció un 15 por ciento
las previsiones del banco central para
2017 no son mejores oscilan entre el 1%
y el 2% si a todo esto le sumamos que a
pesar de todo el crecimiento tres de
cada cuatro chilenos ganan menos de 700
dólares al mes ya os podéis imaginar el
cabreo porque amigos esos salarios de
país rico no tienen nada en otras
palabras hoy el modelo chileno hace
aguas por cierto para los que nos estáis
viendo desde chile quiero que sepáis que
aprecio mucho vuestro país de hecho
estuve una pequeña temporada viviendo
muy cerquita de la moneda vamos que ni
el mote con huesillo ni las empanadas de
pino me son cosas extrañas
pero volviendo al tema que nos ocupa el
principal responsable de este frenazo
tiene un nombre y apellido michelle
bachelet la actual presidenta de la
república
[Música]
la revolución de bachelet
algunos analistas comparan la evolución
política de chile con la de españa ambos
países sufrieron una dura dictadura
militar seguida de una transición donde
primero gobernó una izquierda moderada
luego la derecha y finalmente ambos
terminaron con gobiernos de una
izquierda más rupturista
es decir el papel de felipe gonzález
sería en chile- el de patricio aylwin
eduardo frei ricardo lagos y la propia
bachelet en su primera etapa y por otro
lado el papel de josé maría aznar sería
el de sebastián piñera
bachelet hoy en esta última legislatura
equivaldría en españa' a nuestros
tiempos con josé luís rodríguez zapatero
el caso es que tras ganar las elecciones
presidenciales en 2013 y ser nombrada de
nuevo presidenta michelle bachelet puso
en marcha un programa mucho más agresivo
decidido a incrementar el
intervencionismo del gobierno y el gasto
público
y si lo hizo su primera gran apuesta
atentos fue subir los impuestos a las
empresas casi un 40 por ciento ahí es
nada
lo hizo subiendo el tipo sobre
beneficios y eliminando también una
bonificación por la cual las empresas
que reinvertían sus beneficios en chile-
reducían el pago de impuestos si lo
pensáis es muy razonable un país como
chile que aún está lejos de los países
más ricos lo que necesita son fábricas
máquinas negocios tecnología vamos en
definitiva inversión así que ya me
contaréis qué sentido tiene castigar
precisamente eso la inversión pues
precisamente es lo que hizo bachelet y
ojo porque los impuestos de las empresas
en chile no son precisamente bajos tras
la reforma de bachelet chile es el
segundo país que en términos relativos
más impuestos cobra las empresas sólo
por detrás de japón que desde luego es
un país mucho más rico y con empresa
mucho más consolidada
queréis saber qué consecuencias ha
tenido esta medida pues que la inversión
se ha desplomado nada menos que un 30%
desde que bachelet regresó al palacio de
la moneda y claro todos sabemos que
menos inversión supone menos empleos
menos crecimiento y por tanto menos
recaudación en otras palabras el
gobierno de chile quiso comerse el
pastel antes siquiera de cocinarlo y eso
la verdad nunca suele funcionar
[Música]
por esta razón en los últimos años hay
una tendencia a reducir los impuestos a
las empresas
canadá reino unido irlanda o incluso la
francia de macrón son algunos ejemplos
de países que bien han reducido los
impuestos corporativos bien planean
hacerlo chile va en dirección contraria
pero esperad un momento porque aquí no
acaba todo las otras dos grandes
reformas de bachelet han tenido un
resultado similar aunque abordaremos
estas reformas con más profundidad en un
próximo vídeo de momento van dos apuntes
la reforma laboral ha encarecido a la
contratación y se ha centrado en
reforzar el poder de los sindicatos
algunos todo esto puede sonarles muy
bien pero supone aún más costes para las
empresas lo que sumado a la subida que
hemos visto en los impuestos pues aún
menos inversión menos competitividad y
menos exportaciones
vamos el cóctel completo por otro lado
con la reforma educativa la presidenta
bachelet quiso algo así como
nacionalizar las universidades pero esta
reforma tampoco le ha salido bien y sólo
ha podido aprobarla parcialmente eso sí
tener una cosa bien presente convertir a
las universidades en fábricas de títulos
por muy gratuitas que sean no va a
resolver los problemas de movilidad
social que tiene un chile que es la
verdadera enfermedad que afecta al país
pero puede que os estáis preguntando qué
piensan los chilenos
pues atentos a un 62 por ciento de los
chilenos considera que el gobierno de
michelle bachelet debe retirar o moderar
las reformas que viene imponiendo en el
país austral en especial la educativa la
sensación que existe amigos es que
bachelet quería más un cambio ideológico
que una fórmula que resolviese problemas
[Música]
el resultado de todas estas reformas y
de la versión del gobierno por la
empresa privada que ha generado mucha
incertidumbre ha sido la peor
legislatura en términos económicos que
chile ha tenido en décadas y sabéis
quién sale más perjudicado de esta
situación exacto como siempre los más
pobres y la clase trabajadora al fin y
al cabo la gente con dinero vive siempre
bien el caso es que bachelet deja un
país en crisis con déficit públicos
crecientes con el gasto público más
elevado de los últimos 26 años y con un
sector productivo muy tocado
[Música]
por supuesto la presidenta también se
marcha sin haber diversificado la
economía ni haber corregido sus
problemas más importantes cuáles son
veámoslos
[Música]
los puntos débiles de chile
si algo es un hecho es que chile es un
país bastante hostil a los profesionales
extranjeros es raro que un país que ha
crecido tanto y que se ha convertido en
el país más rico de latinoamérica haya
sido incapaz de atraer a profesionales
de fuera tan sólo el 2% de la población
chilena es inmigrante y eso es un
problema que afecta al emprendimiento a
la innovación y al comercio porque en
chile no crece porque está lleno de
chileno
por lo general los profesionales
extranjeros por ejemplo tienden a hacer
más emprendedores lo que ayuda a
diversificar y a desarrollar la economía
en el propio chile los inmigrantes
tienen una tasa de emprendimiento que
multiplica por 4 a la de la población
local un segundo problema es que el
ascensor social no funciona esto es no
hay cambios entre clases sociales el que
nace abajo muere abajo y el que no hacia
arriba muere arriba de hecho se dice que
el país está de facto controlado por
apenas 7 familias cuya riqueza equivale
al 17 por ciento del pib nacional esto a
alguno puede parecerle que no es
importante pero cuando el ascensor
social y la competencia no funcionan
significa que el apellido se antepone al
mérito y al esfuerzo el coste de
oportunidad que esto tiene para un país
es enorme por no hablar de que estas
familias suelen tener relaciones un
tanto especiales con el poder mirad
mirad
el hijo de bachelet ante la justicia por
un caso de corrupción
andrónico luksic uno de los hombres más
poderosos de chile- y propietario del
banco de chile está implicado en la
trama y si a bachelet también le ha
salpicado la corrupción luego amigos
está la burocracia seguro que habéis
escuchado que chile es una economía muy
libre bien pues cuando la conoces
también tienes claro que es muy
burocrática no te lo crees pues bien
sólo tienes que intentar siendo
extranjero hacerte con un root un rol
único tributario que es un documento
imprescindible para llevar a cabo
operaciones comerciales básicas como
contratar internet en tu casa
también puedes probar hacer algo tan
simple como abrirte una cuenta bancaria
prueba y que tengas suerte
[Música]
quiere eso por ejemplo pues bien la
regulación chilena impide incluso
importar coches de segunda mano mark
twain dijo que hay tres clases de
mentiras las mentiras las medias
mentiras y las estadísticas puede que
los números de chile tengan algo de eso
las elecciones el caso es que el 19 de
noviembre de 2017 se celebran elecciones
en chile aún no están decididos los
candidatos al menos en el momento de
publicar este vídeo pero ya hay dos
claros favoritos alejandro guillier y
sebastián piñera alejandro guillier es
un periodista recién llegado a la
política cuyos planteamientos no están
del todo claros más allá de su pasión
por china pero eso sí supone más de lo
mismo por otro lado sebastián piñera fue
presidente de chile entre 2010 y 2014
fue el primer presidente de
centroderecha desde que chile recobró la
democracia tras la terrible etapa de
pinochet y lo cierto es que su papel al
frente de la moneda fue bastante
positivo a pesar de la crisis financiera
y del terrible terremoto que el país
padeció en 2010 el crecimiento económico
de chile en su mandato fue el triple que
el de bachelet en esta legislatura algo
está claro si chile quiere recobrar la
buena marcha amigos tiene que virar el
rumbo bueno y tú qué piensas cómo
valoras a bachelet con quién irías con
piñera
espero tus respuestas en los comentarios
si te ha gustado el vídeo recuerda darle
al like y no olvides suscribirte al
canal si aún no lo has hecho también
aprovecho para recordarte que puedes
encontrarnos en facebook twitter y
también ahora en instagram en los
últimos vídeos os lo han hecho tanto
enrique como consejero yo también quiero
daros personalmente las gracias a todos
aquellos que es desechando una mano
aviso al político con vuestras
donaciones en paypal y gracias a todos
por animarnos a seguir con este canal ya
plantearnos hacer otras muchas más cosas
un saludo y hasta la próxima
por cierto si te has quedado con ganas
de ver otro vídeo te recomiendo este
sobre nuestros océanos ya me contarás
qué te parece
[Música]